and I would just say yes I want Jordan
pulling those guys - I'm sorry proving
those guys to get better but teams
aren't great for that they're coming at
you oh yeah waterboy barking hello
Russell Russell
beautiful move here by Russell - a
strong hand the left hand start a
preseason for LeBron James and also
pulled it back on the Colville pulpit
went to the left and to fight at home
and Marv
you know we we've seen it already
usually didn't have to do that but you
have so many new players you have to
reach implement your sister [ __ ] you
want two and a half hours at one point
what is it a teaching Modi's they study
jordan bullhead is backed out of the
warrior walker this query on the drive
the lot of new faces here a lot of
teaching happening right now
angelo thrown it back that's it so you
know here's free roll screen rolling
pick and Robinson play to Baltimore dome
into the mist
hurry in transition staff another
[Applause]
there's a big dollar you that's defense
turn to offense until weakens try to
reach in from the back you can't do that
against Steph
though the love lean worked
until Russell curry continued Angela
from the elbow the basketball game
action that he's getting more
comfortable is hit a couple jumpers ties
is over layman again and he's gonna
score from just about everywhere on the
floor
[Music]
here's in college a six pick overall
step right through the tables beefier
than layman Angelo sorting people to run
through the legs crossover little bid
range jumper just thank you [ __ ] to
get six points set that screen the
Stefan D'Angelo going to work together
but there's a screen right there Andrew
Wiggins is closing out he has to fight
over every once in a while you just
amazed a pick-and-roll just like that
[Applause]
hurry they like him you've been killing
all games taking playoff or something
well I said this before to good
defensive plays ignited the war you're
fast blink convince the defensive lapse
four minutes to go in the quarter
reporter by Glenn Robinson Casey white
house right Howard
look at this rebound by step just ended
badly
great job flexing a little bit Steph
Sean curry the seventh pick back mm and
not ten-point going half a minute to
play first half step Gary the leaves
just amazing former Laker was the number
two picked by Los Angeles back in 2015
but was it all start with Brooklyn a
year ago and a nice pass to Chris but a
throw down to start things off come on
Scottie and Mike there's some great ones
Byrd and several other guys right
Fitbit lettuce laughs Kobe and Shaq Yeti
you can't challenge any call if there's
an on call you can't challenge s be a
foul called on the floors rustles start
to get going buries a three got twenty
points now this is your first game with
him will either be in LA or Texas I'm
taking a wild guess that God does not
leave come on Russell hits a three and
four white jerseys around the ball the
other aspect of rebounding is his
preseason and Chris write down all right
steps is looking at the weak side piece
is expecting the ball to right
here's your pick and roll he's rolling
the basket look at the weak side they're
there but they don't cut a bomb Devon
take a cog before your college player
able to lay that up and in monster by
lava actually and we're gonna just call
that the LOB Marquis Chris just leaning
on look at Kentavious caldwell-pope
making a business decision try to get
fancy jump away from you make it easier
on them one more right corner step out
see
he's saying all right he's penetrating I
got a slide out of the base line so he
can see me such a good pass or such a
great ball handler smooth he's got a
great vision I mean he sees it before
the play develops just really good at
figuring that part out I mean you know
and just damsel Russell running with
Perkins
[Music]
good answer Russell he's full speed he
sees Kentavious caldwell-pope just kind
of holds him up there then just bounces
off of so there's nothing Kentavious
could do he was totally out of the plate
while she takes his cone behind him he's
like that's the guy that could block
much I'm not worried about Jared Dudley
yes
no one ever slows down to size Chris
barely in his hands give it up Chris
found him Jared Dudley just not close
enough that is Steph Curry and his
jumper is water leak induce stretch -
flourished in spots up and knocks down
open shot shot 35% last year for Bri
draymond Green think Stefan draymond
look rejuvenated
[Music]
[Applause]
pick-and-roll means Kobe era stream in
the Lakers deflected Angelo Hilo in a
footrace in LA
three and this would be great if this
was regular season dress rehearse
without some active hands on thief
tennis press with the Lakers in the
preseason
[Applause]
with a free-throw coming right across
the shooting hand in the Khans act will
step back get separation what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content